let's get back into lore hunting and
look into the interesting wraith callers
that we can find in the lorenia regions
in a couple other areas of the lands
between if we take a closer look we can
see that they are hunched over humanoid
creatures with four arms they can be
found at lorenia Lakes the laskar ruins
the Shaded Castle the lunar estate ruins
the sainted hero's grave and Altus
plateau and even in the Subterranean
shunning grounds we can also find a
group of wraith callers near the Bellum
highway to the south of the frenzied
flank Village this group seems to be
guarding the eye of yellik which is a
craftable item that grows in the lands
afflicted by frenzy and is used for its
pain relieving properties however this
item is also known to be a dangerous
intoxicant so why would wraith callers
be guarding this pain relieving item I
think there's something to this wraith
callers come in a few different ways
some are just wandering the world on
foot and will attack using their
multiple arms some ride erratically on
near skeletal-like horses and some wield
The Wraith calling Bell which is a
weapon that summons prowling rates that
slowly tracks you the description of
this Bell says that the rates are
vengeful spirits of those who died when
cursed and that this Bell is used by
those who worship revenants revenants
are much like The Wraith callers just
even more disgusting to look at with
even more limbs that seem to be grafted
to their bodies making them look more
spider-like than human the revenants are
much more aggressive than The Wraith
callers and are also capable of
traveling through portals to take their
enemies off guard now I could be wrong
here but I think it's safe to compare
The Wraith callers and revenants to the
grafted Scions the multiple limbs
spider-like movement and humanoid
features are obvious comparisons but a
bit deeper reason for comparing them is
what they stand for as we said wraith
callers use The Wraith calling Bell to
some in vengeful spirits of those who
died when cursed there could be many
different curses in the lands between
but what I believe it's referring to
here are the Omens The Omen biting a
consumable item depicting a doll of a
curse born biting when used unleashes
rates to chase down foes its description
says that almond babies have all their
horns removed causing most to die its
description ends with a quote that says
please don't hate me or curse me please
I believe it's possible that the
vengeful spirits of those who died when
cursed from The Wraith calling Bell are
these Omens who died when their horns
were removed in addition there are many
Omens who don't have their horns removed
and are instead banished through the
sewers below the capital city wrapped
underground for the rest of their lives
unbeknownst to anyone according to the
Regal Omen Byron which can also be used
to unleash Ray dates to chase down foes
also says that these Omen are from the
ERD trees golden line born of royalty
but since they were born Omen like
morgot or Moog they were banished the
Royal Line whether it was during or
before the current royal line of Queen
America Godfrey and radagon it's likely
that they kept trying over and over
again to have children who were not born
Omen every birth of an omen just meant
throwing them away and trying again
until they got it right I don't know
about you but if I were born in Almond
I'd be pretty vengeful for being Cast
Away just for being born morgant and
Moog are vengeful in different ways
morgot is doing everything he can to
prove to his golden lineage that he is
worthy of his Royal status that was
taken away from him at Birth Moog went
the opposite route disregarding the
golden order entirely and starting
something new on his own with the
formless mother so how is this similar
to the Scions it if we read the
description of the ornamental straight
sword used by the Scions it tells us
that after falling from Grace the dregs
of the golden lineage sought power and
purpose in the past they also used the
Golden Crest Shield which shows a
depiction of sarash who according to the
description of The Shield is an aged
counselor who guides the golden lineage
to me this is referring to Godfrey and
his tarnished Warriors banished from the
lands between by Queen America to the
Badlands after losing their sight of
Grace but why are weapons of a Scion
referring to the tarnished while we know
from rodurika that the limbs grafted
onto the Scions and even godric are the
body parts of the tarnished everyone's
been grafted everyone who came with me
they crossed the sea for me they fought
for me
only to have their arms taken
their legs taken even their heads taken
taken and stuck to the spider he also
tells us that when you're grafted by the
spider you become a chrysalid the
Chrysalis Memento shows faintly visible
Spirits trying to convey something but
their voices cannot be heard after their
banishment the tarnish became dregs
which just means the lowest part of
something the dregs of society used as
sacrifices for the grotesque acts of
grafting slowly tarnished not unfit even
to craft under Godfrey and his golden
lineage as Warriors they fought for the
golden order and battled anyone who
opposed them once all the battles were
won their Grace was taken away from them
and they were banished used for their
purpose and then thrown away afterward
not too far from the fate of the Omens
who were also thrown away to the sewers
below or to die at Birth maybe The
Wraith callers are taking the spirits of
the omen to be use for something more
maybe this is why a group of wraith
callers were guarding the eye of yell it
could be used to ease the pain and
suffering of the vengeful spirits that
they can call upon with their Bell it
may be a toxic ailment only grown in a
place consumed by the flame of frenzy
but it's at least some type of ailment
for them in a way the three fingers and
its flame of frenzy are just like the
omen banished and hidden away far below
the Earth tree forgotten and disregarded
waiting for the right moment to take its
Vengeance on the world that cast it
aside it's not like they can use
fundamental healing incantations if they
wanted The Wraith callers and revenants
are the only creatures in the game who
are actually hurt or damaged by
incantations like heel great heal Lord's
heel ER tree heal and blessings of the
earth tree maybe the vengeful spirits of
the Omens that they can call upon and
the limbs of the tarnish that they now
wields won't allow these creatures to be
healed by the very thing that caused
them this pain and suffering in the
first place there are even theories that
the finger readers and even Ronnie could
have similarities to The Wraith callers
and revenants since Ronnie's doll has
multiple arms like The Wraith collars
it's widely known at this point that
Ronnie's doll is modeled after her
Mentor Rena so it's possible that Ronnie
was mentored by a potential wraith
caller Ronnie even gives us a similar
Bell that can summon Spirits instead of
rates zoly the witch has made a couple
videos about this around a month ago and
I urge you to go watch them if you
haven't already it could lead to more
interesting discoveries if we all work
together on what this could potentially
mean all in all we really don't know
that much about The Wraith callers the
revenants the rates that they can summon
from these bells we'll have to wait for
more information to surface and we can
get there if we work together like I
said I'll leave these videos Linked In
in the description for you to watch
there could be many more reasons for all
of this as well and I'd love to hear
what you all think in the comments if
I'm way off the Mark here let me know if
you think there are other comparisons to
be made let me know as well I think it
can lead to many different videos and
many different discussions that we can
have as a community so thank you all for
watching subscribe if you want to and
I'll see you all in the next video take
care